- One of the great things about
adopting an infinite mindset
is I've stopped looking at things
in terms of right, wrong, good, bad.
But taking things more in
terms of context, right?
So I'm not against finite games.
If you're in a finite game,
you have to play with a finite mindset.
But if you're in an infinite game,
you have to play with an infinite mindset.
And with an infinite game, of
course there are finite games.
Of course, you have a product to make
that has to get out on time
and there's a beginning, middle, and end,
and you have to meet your deadlines.
And we get these products out on time
and meet our finite objectives
in order to advance the
infinite vision, right?
So for example, I'll give
you a perfect example.
So we're constantly told
to know our strengths and
our weaknesses, right?
Build on your strengths,
mitigate your weaknesses.
Are they strengths?
Are they weaknesses?
Or is it all context, right?
So if you are very self-confident,
sometimes you're arrogant.
So in other words, a strength
can actually have liability,
but our weaknesses
sometimes have strengths.
I'll give you a perfect example.
I am chronically disorganized.
I mean, it's embarrassing, right?
And this I've always believed
was a horrible weakness.
And I beat myself up for it.
And I say how I need to fix this.
And I try all these systems
that don't really work,
because you have to be organized
to have an organized system.
I'll give you a perfect example
of just how disorganized I am.
As a young entrepreneur,
when I was just starting out,
I would go to a networking event,
and of course you collect business cards.
And a good entrepreneur,
an organized entrepreneur,
would take a business card from a prospect
if somebody goes, "I think
you're great, here's my card."
And they would have sent
an email on the cab home
and followed up the next day and be like,
would love to set up a meeting
and come and show you our product.
Yahoo over here would
lose the business card
from the time I got it to
the time I got home, right?
Two weeks later, I'd find
it under a pile of things,
sort of brush off the dust bunnies.
And I'd call them up and say,
"Hey, remember we met at
that event two weeks ago?"
They wanted to work with me even more
'cause they thought I was busy!
Is disorganized a bad thing?
The answer is context.
Sometimes, yeah, it
really is, but not always.
And so now when I look at myself,
or I look at the weaknesses or strengths
even of my own organization,
I no longer think in terms
of right wrong, good, bad.
But I rather think this is
really valuable in this context,
this is really dangerous in this context.
So I can mitigate, and move things around,
and understand what to leverage.
So it's much more about
balance and context
than it is about right, wrong, good, bad.
And all of this has come
from learning to adopt
this infinite mindset, that
I'm never a loser or a winner.
I'm just ahead and behind.
Sometimes I'm ahead and sometimes behind,
but I've never won and I've never lost.